I'm gonna get right into it today okay
because I've got something on my mind
business yeah I am you know I do mean
business and I just want your opinion on
something been very happily married for
a long time now to my lovely wife Liza
you've known Liza for a very long time
girl you've met Liza it's wonderful
wonderful person she's right and um yeah
whatever this is she's right okay well
here's my
problems okay we grew up differently oh
yeah she grew up in a very sensible home
okay she has one sister when you go to
their home it's very sensible they're
lovely people they're sane everything's
just so you know and you contrast that
with the way that I grew up and again I
love my parents and and my siblings but
there was a lot of us when my parents
would go to the grocery store store they
would uh first of all before we could go
with them they would have to buy a lot
of food and then when we could go we of
course were just terrible rotten kids
and we would just throw because there's
so many gross grocery carts because
there's so many people in the family my
grandmother lived with us and we would
throw all kinds of crud into the grocery
cart that we could you know process junk
food and my mother would try to weed it
all out at the checkout line but of
course you can't it's too much and we
she's weeding some of it out but we're
sneaking it back in and then we get home
and there's you know literally just
awful you know cheese flavored puffed up
stuff made by uh you know filled with
chemicals called dippity-dappity doo
doos stuff that they later found out was
just chock full of dangerous toxic
chemicals and it's now in a landfill
somewhere uh but anyway so that was the
kind of way I grew up and we were
voracious eaters and still you've seen
me eat soda it's terrible it's
terrifying it's like yeah you eat like
you have siblings looming over you yeah
really quickly so anyway I was the other
day hanging out with with Liza and she
just mentioned she said yeah I'm off I'm
off to the market and get some stuff and
I went great great so I'm just whatever
as you do you regress and I'm getting
hungry and I'm thinking about her coming
in with bags and bags of just like food
and I'm forgetting that I married this
sensible person yeah you know and uh so
I'm imagining there's going to be
Doritos oh no and uh Captain Crunch and
just a giant a giant roast turkey that's
got gravy on it already and uh there's
gonna be you know some some Swedish Fish
and then there's going to be like three
milkshakes and a couple of hamburgers
that have been you know you sound like
you're high I'm just yeah exactly she
comes in and she's all happy
and I'm like oh good what'd you get and
she said well I got some fresh almonds
and I got some blackberries oh you know
what Liza isn't right no but then I
found out in her defense and so I'm like
what
what and then I found out that she went
to the farmer's market but still even if
I went to the farmer's market if I got
almonds and blackberries I would I don't
know on the way home I'd stop at a
7-Eleven and I'd force them at gum point
to make me a ham sandwich using pieces
of slim jim you know like I would do
something I'm now I'm getting really
hungry and she went oh it's fun and of
course you know she's very beautiful and
but she said it's fine and you know I
see her eating a couple of nuts and hmm
I'm drinking a little tea with it and
then I'm having my blackberries and
everything's just and I know that her
parents would be like oh yes good for
you you know yes you're so angry and you
know her parents went well there's two
of us so we'll have two children and
that just evens things out now uh six
almonds for each of you and let's have
some tea and that was good everyone take
a nap but first I'll walk around the
pond oh this goes and in my family
do you resent Liza for getting so much
attention and love from when she was was
young and you had to share it yes doctor
yes okay so this is not about elements
and blackberries it kind of is because
when you're hungry and you're 6'4 right
198 pounds of pure muscle okay okay I've
been to your house and you guys always
have a lot of good food I know I was
just in this moment looking at it was
just making I was looking at these
almonds raw almonds not even salted and
roasted that's problematic because
roasted and almond that might have some
dangerous
nutrients in there
oh my God you are charged no I'm just uh
am I wrong and so I actually she cares
about you my health I cupped my hands
and I put some almonds in there and I
put a few blackberries and I really did
feel like I was someone who had been my
plane had gone down three weeks ago and
I had wandered through through and I was
about to die but I found a couple of
nuts and a couple of berries
and just was stuffing them into my face
and then people came we're coming over
then and they were like oh hey Conan I'm
like and I had Blackberry around my lips
you know when a vampire sees a question
don't touch my blackberries and of
course she's perfectly fine she's like
oh man am I stuffed if she brought home
Doritos and like a ham sandwich made of
Slim Jims you would have eaten it you
would have been really happy then
afterwards you would have been really
upset at yourself wouldn't you uh no I
would have blacked out in a revenue I
remember when you and I would have
awoken in like with a sensual High I
remember when you and I ate the McRib oh
that was okay well let's not get in
trouble with a major company is it Darth
why can't we jump at McDonald's I love
McDonald's
ever offended a major company I don't
ever want to hear it from you again
let's not get in trouble with the mate
you wouldn't even name the name of the
company
apology I'm loving it oh my God
major company
I will not offend any group of white men
that have formed a corporate concern for
a prophet they shall be protected on
Conan O'Brien needs a friend oh my God
that's why you're mad at Liza she didn't
bring home a Big Mac yeah oh my God I
could have killed a Big Mac man that
company does it right always have good
and always will I'm a Burger King fan
myself well them too oh you can't go
wrong with those big companies I'm a
Taco Bell boy yep
you know who's good at drilling for oil
Texaco
in my opinion keep at it fellas get that
Liquid Gold anywho I think my wife's
right and in her defense she was just
going to the farmer's market but she's
always been that way I think on our
first date I said you want to get lunch
and she said oh I'm okay I just had two
walnuts and some green tea and I almost
jumped out a window because for me lunch
involves at least four whole hams
[Laughter]
anyway my apologies to my in-laws
and my wife and to McDonald's
no apology to McDonald's wait what I
said the McRib was garbage it's not
garbage that's pretty bad it's not
I'm loving it keep making those McRibs
whatever you do is right well anyway now
on to
Bell helicopters
maker of military helicopters and damn
good ones we're done stop all right I'm
down here